if only we could all become a little bit
more animal again I think that we would
be happier
great sexier being there's no
geographical context that can tell you
what you cannot do my making me to shake
it on my cam in the PM when men want to
abuse women
it happened daddy like I said he had a
baby at a time when Arab Americans find
themselves under the microscope and
spotlight of suspicion two young women
are breaking barriers using similar
messages but different approaches
[Music]
you know I started writing poetry in my
kindergarten journals and it's just
always been a part of my identity and
who I am when I heard Alanis Morissette
and I was nine years old I'll never
forget I felt a sense of permission it
felt like permission to be a woman and
to be strong and to be angry and to not
be contained
[Music]
I grew up the same subconsciously pops
like Lauren Hill like common like just
at different artists he just spoke to my
soul you know they weren't just telling
me to like take my movie I felt like I
had to have permission from muck you
know from my society and from people
around me and from my friends I was
living to appease everyone else's truth
[Music]
like you have the black kids you have
the brown kids and like Here I am
hijab me I'm some woman who covers who
has very light skin like where did I fit
in like all young adults both Rotana
and Mona a Syrian American are searching
for purpose and meaning in their life
I'm from Saudi Arabia there was no one
growing up that I could point to and say
oh she tried to break into the music
industry in my mind I decided that it
wasn't possible I had just graduated
from college I started working at an oil
company in Saudi Arabia and I loved it I
was being pushed to the front lines as a
woman and there was such a hole inside
of me and I I just it was tormenting me
and I realized that I had no idea who I
was or what I truly believed in or what
I was here to do on this earth I think I
was very conscious as a young woman in
this world that patriarchy transcends
class religion culture geography borders
it transcends everything they are
worldwide problems and it doesn't matter
what religion they believe in it isn't
what color their skin is you know they
will do it I had to get I have to go
through a depression to come out on the
other side can people ask me all the
time how did you come to music I have no
idea I got depressed and I started to
hear a voice and it was saying I want
you to try and write and do music and
reading in the ADI like I said he had a
good their struggles are not just
internal they're compounded by the
reality of being born into a culture and
religion Islam that is increasingly
vilified in the u.s. which is home to
both these artists when you mind you put
on when you need a tsunami a lot of
people are saying a lot of different
things about me on the Internet in the
world with their friends and I'm just
working really hard and I think any of
that person usually is when the Sun sets
trying to hunt me down I don't want
people to get too mad at me but I think
Muslims are really afraid of growth our
community is really afraid of evolution
because we love our prophet so deeply
and we're so hesitant to do anything
differently than what
I get a lot of negative commentary on my
social media I mean you can read through
it I'm sure you've seen it and that used
to really hurt me I even it used to make
me question myself I'm doing something
that is new and is different and is not
a norm in my society yet and when you do
that in any society essentially what you
are doing is that you are introducing
people to parts of themselves that they
aren't ready to meet
[Music]
it feels offensive to some people and it
feels like an attack simply because I'm
being myself when religion is just
telling us that this is forbidden this
is for a bit and this is for a bit and
this is permissible this is permissible
this is permissible
that's so narrow it's it's the most
difficult part of my existence it's
something that I battle every day and
saying Ratana I love you I am proud of
you because I know that Who I am is very
offensive to some people in a world that
tells women who look a certain way that
their bodies are not beautiful that they
need to show a certain amount of skin or
their hair in order to be beautiful I
wanted to put something out there that
said hey like whoever you are wherever
you're from whatever you look like I
love you and I think so many young girls
needs to hear that message wrote Ana's
latest song daddy doesn't only refer to
patriarchy and the oppression that comes
with it but both of these young women
told me that oppression is as much a
construct of their own minds as it is
imposed upon them by society the song
daddy is about not allowing anybody to
require you to dilute yourself in order
to make them feel more comfortable and
so daddy is societal expectations daddy
is the bully at school and most of all
daddy is the voice inside of our heads
that are telling us that we can
are you parents concern of course
they're worried about that I have so
many people telling me that I shouldn't
do it that I couldn't do it that nobody
would care go become a doctor and
actually help people you know just like
Mona at first wrote Anna's parents
weren't fully convinced of their
daughters musical ambitions and journey
into the spotlight I was still worried
about my parents and how they're going
to feel about it but now that I've just
lived my truth my parents believe in
magic and I know that sounds so cheesy
but it's real and oh my god this is so
cheesy sorry and I think that when you
live your truth then it makes people
bleeding I want to put it out there that
you know if a man ever tells you that
your salvation is in his hands you can
sound straight up and down but it's not
I love Saudi Arabia and I love my
country and I am proud to be Saudi and I
do this because I believe in the Saudi
youth and the Saudi woman and I believe
in a culture that is free and I think
that we are on our way there if only you
can continue to tell on the stories
one of the things that I really hope
that the song does is it opens up the
conversation on violence against women
globally what is my job it's to tell
those stories and it's to create spaces
that are safe for women to do that it's
not that I wasn't afraid it's just that
I was afraid and I did it anyways we
look to our heroes and we think that
they're not scared I'm so scared I'm I'm
shivering through all of this but every
day I wake up and I make a decision to
commit to Who I am there's this
perception that I don't love my country
that I'm creating segregation between me
and them but I'm doing this because I am
so inspired to come for a place like
Saudi Arabian because we have such a
unique story to tell so I think that's
what a lot of people would be surprised
to hear that I didn't love my country
[Music]
[Applause]
banging my feet slang it's lagging my me
and my HIV ladies we was born in the
eighties to pretty likely euphrates and
party like some Kuwaitis be presenting
diplomas current life from high yoga
taking back from misnomers and
teleporting through trauma
teleport into trauma teleporting trauma
I've a second